la guerra había terminado los locus
estaban muertos y el mundo finalmente
vivía en paz y armonía Ah no mentiras
los cabrones han
vuelto si pensabas que Gears of War 3
había sido un final perfecto para la
serie pues lástima porque años después
el caos y la guerra volverían a tomarse
el planeta cera y Gears of War 4 nos
volvería a transportar a ese mundo en
donde nos destrozamos los unos a los
otros con motosierras nos volamos en
pedazos o nos pisoteando entre todos con
nuestros megasor
gigantes ya saben por la paz después de
un par de años Gears of War ha regresado
trayendo de vuelta todo lo que nos gusta
violencia exagerada destrucción e
incluso a nuestros personajes favoritos
porque sí justo cuando pensábamos que
Marcus ya no podía ser más rudo vuelve
más mamado y con una poderosa barba
vikinga viejo sabroso Gears of War 4 es
el juego al que menos tiempo le he
dedicado en toda la saga pero aún así es
un juego que me entretuvo un montón y
que de hecho disfruté bastante Así que
continuando donde lo dejamos en el video
anterior hoy vamos a explorar el
siguiente juego en la lista uno que
comenzó una nueva era para Gears of War
una particularmente violenta pero igual
de divertida mucha sangre viejos
conocidos y un nuevo enemigo una nueva
guerra se acerca a cera Así que
prepárate y Acompáñame a ver 30
curiosidades secretos y detalles de
Gears of War
[Música]
4 no se escapará tan fácil esta
vez [__] madre lo acababa de arreglar
Gears of War 4 toma lugar 25 años
después de que la guerra locus terminara
aunque ya estábamos acostumbrados al
poderoso escuadrón Delta para este nuevo
comienzo encarnamos al hijo del
legendario Marcus Phoenix quien es
llamado jd siendo su nombre completo
James Dominic Phoenix claramente siendo
un homenaje de su padre en honor a su
hermano caído porque es lo que un hombre
hace después de Casi 6 años ausente este
juego necesitaba tener algo novedoso y
fresco Así que añadieron unas cuantas
mecánicas extra como el atacar Cuerpo A
Cuerpo jalar a tus enemigos de la
cobertura para navajeros e incluso
mecánicas ambientales en forma de las
llamaradas unas tormentas mortales
causadas por el arma de emulsión que
usamos al final del Tercer juego cuando
Microsoft compró la saga se le fue
encargada a un estudio poco conocido
llamado Black tusk quienes al ver que
iban a trabajar en el enorme Gears of
War decidieron comprometerse
completamente con la franquicia
cambiando oficialmente su nombre a the
coalition esto para estar más a la par
con Gears y Porque sonaba mejor Epic
games ya tenía la idea de revivir la
saga y hacer un nuevo juego desde Gears
of War judgment Así que cuando los
derechos fueron cedidos a the coalition
Epic les pasó los conceptos e ideas en
los que habían trabajado durante años
para que tuvieran algo en que guiarse y
que no la fueran a [__] y aunque the
coalition sí usó algunas de estas ideas
terminaron descartando o modificando
muchas
otras la idea original era hacer un
juego con un ambiente mucho más oscuro
para volver a las raíces de Gears
lastimosamente por debates dentro del
estudio y peticiones de la misma
Microsoft terminaron bajándole un poco
al juego dejándolo más ligero y menos
lugubre maniático estúpido lo arruinaste
todo dado a que el juego transcurre 25
años de después de Gears 3 podemos notar
que hay algunos cambios en las Lancer
porque sí antes cortaban bien y mataban
sabroso pero como que lastimaban mucho
los hombros Sabes Así que la mayoría de
Lancer que vemos en el juego ahora
tienen una culata de madera un cañón más
largo y una motosierra más corta Ya
sabes para matar cabrones con más
elegancia muchas de las áreas que
recorremos en el juego están inspiradas
en Italia y su extensa y vivida
vegetación que se ende por las calles
antes de la guerra locust la población
del planeta cera era de más de 400
millones de personas pero para Gears of
War 3 casi todos los humanos fueron
aniquilados quedando menos de un millón
en todo el planeta 25 años después la
población mundial era mayor y ya rondaba
los millones pero debido que aún no eran
suficientes el gobierno de la coc
decidió construir robots para suplir la
necesidad de Human en el ejército estos
robots fueron llamados divis en honor a
su Creador Damon Bird en el Gears of War
original Marcus tenía 36 años Así que
usando mi gigantesco cerebro a toda
potencia y haciendo cálculos matemáticos
se sabe que para este juego Marcus tiene
una edad aproximada de entre 63 a 64
años un poco mayor es verdad Pero ya
sabes lo que dicen Cuanto más arrugada
la pasa es más dulce la fruta Ah sí Y su
hijo jd tiene entre 22 a 23 años Estos
son algunos de los diseños originales y
artes conceptuales para jd y su equipo
ya que estamos en esto de los artes
conceptuales Aquí están los diseños
originales que se consideraron para los
nuevos enemigos del juego el
Enjambre en su momento Gears of War 4
fue tan exitoso que contó con tres
ediciones especiales la primera es la
clásica edición de coleccionista que
contenía una figura de jd en una moto y
un llavero de una granada Luego se hizo
una bellísima edición especial de la
Xbox One para conmemorar el lanzamiento
del juego y finalmente también Tuvo una
edición loot crate una edición especial
solo disponible para Norteamérica esta
contenía una sudadera una camiseta Pines
un libro de arte pósters una réplica de
15 cm de una Lancer y muchas otras cosas
que no pienso mencionar aquí son muchas
Gears of War siempre ha tenido de los
mejores trailers en los videojuegos y el
the Gears of War 4 no se queda atrás es
bellísimo es trágico y tiene un temazo
de fondo en él podemos ver los brazotes
de Marcus tallando las iniciales de su
hijo en un árbol que está plantando y
curiosamente en el acto dos Cuando
llegamos a la casa de Marcus podremos
encontrar este mismo árbol que vimos en
el
tráiler si llevas la Lancer
personalizada que te da Marcus en el
capítulo 2 porque así todo el juego
hasta el capítulo 5 desbloqueará un
logro llamado El sonido del silencio
esto es una referencia a la canción que
aparece en el primer tráiler del juego
llamada The Sound Of Silence
interpretada por la poderosísima banda
disturbed canción Qué bonita canción A
pesar de quea fue un personaje mu
importante en la trilogía original y que
incluso aparece en el tráiler del juego
aquí simplemente desaparece y no se nos
dice un [__] sobre qué pasó con ella A
quién le importa si es la madre nuestro
protagonista quieres saber de ella pues
vete a la
[__] El caso es que a pesar de que se
nos cuenta poco o nada acerca de annia
existe una cinemática secreta que
encontraremos cuando llegamos a la casa
de Marcus y que nos revelará el destino
de
annia
y ya que estábamos hablando de gente
muerta hablemos de
dom Ay ya me puse triste este juego
honra el recuerdo de dom y María
incluyendo un eeg muy bello pero a la
vez trágico Pues cuando llegas al
cementerio si ignoras a los bichos
gigantes tratando de acribillar y le
disparas a unas lápidas en el orden
correcto una espesa Niebla cubrirá todo
el mapa y podrás escuchar la agarradora
escena de La despedida de domy
[Música]
María al final una foto de los dos caerá
al suelo otorgándote una de las armas
más poderosas del juego capaz de matar a
cualquier enemigo de un solo disparo
durante el capítulo 3 de acto 5 cuando
estás piloteando Los Mega que te da Bird
podrás ver dos ramas sospechosamente
posicionadas si pateas un auto en el
centro de estas dos ramas anotarás un
touchdown y escucharás una pequeña parte
del rap del C
[Aplausos]
train
inicialmente solo se tenían personajes
del Enjambre y de la cgo en el
multijugador Así que después de la
insistencia de los fans sobre querer ver
a los locust en el juego The coalition
anunció que sí iban a incluir skins de
estos personajes y para calmar las
ansias hicieron una encuesta a través de
su página web y Twitter para saber qu
locus querían que incluyeran en el juego
antes de realizar Gears of War I el
estudio de coalition antes conocido como
Black tusk trabajó en la Ultimate
Edition esto no sería coincidencia Pues
en realidad esto fue una prueba por
parte de Microsoft que hizo que el
estudio trabajara en este juego primero
para probar su talento y decidir si eran
dignos de continuar con la saga de Gears
durante el prólogo mientras encarnamos a
los soldados de la cooc peleando en el
día e varios rivers tratarán de hacerte
carnitas y normalmente Tendremos que
matarlos a todos con el martillo del
Alba pero si matas únicamente al locust
que los controla el River Se volverá tu
amigo y Podrás montarlo como un
pony en Gears of War 3 existía un error
en donde girando varias veces una
granada y luego interactuando
rápidamente con algún botón causaría que
el juego se congelara y la partida
terminara Esto fue algo muy molesto de
lo que algunos jugadores abusaron y que
la comunidad odió en Gears of War 4 the
coalition solucionó este error y agregó
un pequeño detalle para aquellos que aún
lo intenten Pues si tratas de hacerlo un
pulgar hacia abajo te dará un Madrazo
que te derribará por ser
tramposo si juegas el prólogo en
dificultad locura Y eres lo
suficientemente
Rápido como para llegar a esta puerta
antes de que se cierre encontrarás un
arma de hielo que congelará y acabará
con todos los enemigos de un solo
disparo esto es una referencia al arma
de hielo que usa Gru en mi villano
favorito si juegas en el mapa
multijugador Puerto y le disparas a
siete estatuas de leviatán escondidas a
lo largo de todo el mapa podrás ver como
un leviatán real sale del mar para
saludar
mam huevo digo en una entrevista que se
le realizó a cliff blinski el año pasado
él comentó que creía que la verdadera
razón por la que Epic games vendió los
derechos de Gears of War a Microsoft era
porque ya no sabían Qué hacer con la
franquicia Epic necesitaba dinero
urgente y no querían complicarse con
todo el proceso de crear más juegos
Además de que la mayoría del equipo
original de Gears se había marchado de
la empresa por lo que sin saber ver cómo
manejar correctamente la saga decidieron
venderla a Microsoft en esta misma
entrevista cliff también mostró su
disgusto con algunas decisiones de los
nuevos juegos por ejemplo spoilers de
Gear 5 él pensó que la idea de dejar la
decisión de quién Muere al final de Gear
5 era algo poco práctico para el estudio
cliff aseguró que aunque los nuevos
juegos son muy buenos les falta el
corazón y la esencia de los originales
Ustedes tres creen que son mucho mejores
que yo no digas [__] Mary Jane el
jefe final del juego es esta enorme cosa
rosada con tentáculos Que terminamos
haciendo carnitas pero aunque es muy
fuerte y se ve genial nunca más volvemos
a ver a ninguna criatura similar a esta
en ninguno de los dos juegos a esta
criatura se le conoce como la bestia del
Enjambre Y aunque no ha sido confirmado
oficialmente se cree que esta criatura
es única en todo el Enjambre Y si había
solo una ya la matamos Ups uno de los
mejores saseg del juego lo encontraremos
en la casa de Marcus como sabemos a dom
le gustaba mucho sembrar sus tomates Así
que para preservar este recuerdo de su
hermano caído una vez acabó la guerra
Marcus comenzó a sembrar tomates en su
casa durante la campaña pasaremos por
este lugar y de hecho lucharemos ahí
[__] van a dañar mis [__] tomates si
somos unos cabrones y destruimos toda su
cosecha podremos escuchar a Marcus muy
enojado decir todas las groserías que se
sabe it fuck my tomatoes up God damn it
add that to the fucking list God damnit
Those are doms for Christ sees I grew
Those from dom
seeds fuck Those are doms goddamn seeds
for Christ sakes I'm Never Gonna have a
fucking good sauce
Again I can't make dumb
sauce Fuck you guys this
bullshit fucking Damon be You're a cock
huh alabado es la grosería más fuerte
que he oído además si destruimos todas
las plantas de tomate el juego nos
regalará unas granadas especiales
llamadas los juguetitos de dom unos
super tomates explosivos ridículamente
poderosos a lo largo del juego podemos
encontrar una gran cantidad de variantes
únicas de las armas que ya conocemos
tenemos una Lancer especial de color
chistoso que lanza balas de pintura una
nasher única de color dorado llamada el
bucanero furioso que ralentiza el tiempo
cada vez que disparas para tener más
tiempo de apreciar las tripas volando y
también una versión del boomshot que ya
todos conocemos pero que les pertenece a
los robots Así que en lugar de disparar
una granada como usualmente lanza una
bolita enorme Y
explosiva en diciembre del año pasado
cliff lesinski a través de Twitter
reveló los conceptos e ideas que tenía
para la nueva trilogía de Gears of War
antes de retirarse de Epic usando una
Inteligencia artificial para ayudarse a
ilustrar sus poderosas ideas publicó en
Twitter todos estos artes conceptuales
de cómo quería que fueran los nuevos
locust cliff compartía la idea de The
coalition de hacer que los locust
evolucionaran Pero él quería tomar un
rumbo más arriesgado dándole a los
locust a las noos y un aspecto mucho más
demoníaco además como quería que los
enemigos nos jodiera desde cualquier
lugar también consideró enemigos
acuáticos como un Boomer submarino y un
ticker de agua esto nos da una idea de
La otra cara de Gears of War 4 el juego
que nunca
[Música]
vimos luego de pasar 5 años sin en un
nuevo juego este no cuenta eres una
[__] decepción Gears of War 4 comenzó
una nueva etapa para la saga Ya sé ya sé
tal vez cambió un par de cosas y el
juego no terminó de convencer a algunas
personas pero por lo menos para mí fue
una gran experiencia ver resurgir a una
de mis sagas favoritas Además de que nos
devolvió nuestra buena ración de sangre
y violencia lo [__] así que sí no me
quejo este juego tuvo un Gameplay muy
divertido venía con unos graficazos e
incluyó muchas cosas que fueron muy
interesantes de jugar además dado a que
este fue el juego que trajo de vuelta a
la saga quería dedicarle un video
bastante especial con muchos datos que
espero te hayan entretenido ya cubrimos
en su totalidad la trilogía original de
Gears Así que con este video damos
inicio a la nueva trilogía que iremos
explorando video por video Y si sale un
Gear 7 pues Hey de [__] madre no te
olvides de apoyar el canal y echarle un
vistazo a la función de miembros y como
de costumbre Cuéntame en los comentarios
qué te parecieron todos estos datos Y si
tienes sugerencias de qué juego quieres
ver en el próximo video hasta la
[Música]
próxima
se